joining me now is nobel laureate new
york times columnist and distinguished
professor of economics paul krugman paul
thanks so much for coming back on the
show you're one of the economists
pushing back against inflation concerns
you said in a tweet do the math gdp will
be about 300 trillion over the next
decade
3.5 trillion partially paid for with tax
hikes isn't an inflation threat why then
does that remain a talking point when it
comes to this bill one that even
democrats like manchin and cinema buy
into
well it's it's an easy point and you
know people there's something about
inflation that makes people go kind of
lose lose their sense of a proportion
they start to go wild about you know
it's suddenly it's going to be 1979
again and it's just it's just they lose
their proportion but for you know
i think what is probably worth saying is
that
i i don't think senators it depends who
i mean but uh i'm sure that many
senators really haven't done the math
they don't have a sense of
3.5 trillion is a lot of money sounds
like it must be a really big deal on
every front and to have the perspective
to say yeah but you know we're talking
about doing that
an economy that's going to produce
around 300 trillion around 300 trillion
dollars worth of stuff over the next
decade during which the money will be
spent uh that they just don't know that
uh and they are or they're choosing not
to but i think there's some genuine
ignorance they really don't understand
that this is not a big deal and they're
also
the bit about debt means that look i
don't actually think in the end the
uh buying proposals will be fully paid
for with taxes one way or another there
will be some smoke and mirrors but they
will be largely paid for and if you're
going to largely pay for it then
even the tiny inflationary pressure that
we might be talking about
uh goes away i mean you know if we if we
pay for
child care with taxes on
on the wealthy then the economy as a
whole spends more on child care and
spends less on super yachts and
helicopters to the hamptons and
overall it's not inflationary at all
it sounds as if some of these senators i
know you teach economics for a living
could do with a lesson in macroeconomics
it's amazing how so many of our top
leaders elected politicians don't
understand
issues like the debt issues like the
deficit even the debate about
pay fors i feel like it's 2021 we've
been talking about pay falls since 2008
we've been talking about the need to pay
for things and deficits being bad i
thought we'd won this argument at least
amongst liberals or centrists or
democrats and yet again even after
donald trump came into office passed an
unpaid for tax cut we still have
democrats droning on about the need to
pay for things to pay for themselves
i i talk a lot i've even written a book
about zombie ideas things that just you
know should be dead but they just keep
on shambling along and eating people's
brains and um this yeah i mean fiscal
responsibility of course is only for
democrats and the the fact that there's
now a pretty wide consensus among
serious economists that the debt is not
a problem and nowhere close being a
problem at current levels has not i
think made its way through to the uh to
the policy-making elite um within the
buying administration they get it but
then i'm sure that a lot of senators
even on the democratic side are still
living uh you know a decade ago they
still haven't haven't caught on that
that we've learned something
yeah and let's talk about inflation uh
because even some uh very quote unquote
very serious people people you know well
like larry summers have kind of sounded
the alarm on that we did see new numbers
regarding inflation today consumer
prices in july were up 5.4 percent from
the year prior but so-called core
inflation is slowing down what does that
all mean for average americans who are
seeing their grocery bills or their
gas bills their cars that they're buying
get more expensive where do you predict
this will all go as the pandemic
continues and what does it mean for
democrats politically
well um a lot depends on how long this
goes on and uh um you know that that was
not
inflation is still running pretty hot
but uh you know some of us are talking
about team transitory those of us who
believe that we're looking at just kind
of a a bunch of temporary disruptions as
the economy tries to get itself back
together for after the pandemic
and the if you look at to the details
the numbers it looked a lot like you
know some of the things that have gone
way up in price are starting to level
off or even come down like used cars and
there's no sign that the inflation in
those very special
areas is spreading to the rest of the
economy so this is probably you know not
for sure
this is not uh exact science but but all
of this is probably a story for the next
few months and then we'll be able to
look back probably uh by the time the
midterm elections come around and say
what was all that fuss about this was we
did not fundamentally have an inflation
problem
what do you make just returning to joe
manchin and larry summers both of their
concerns that it's dangerous for
congress to spend as if we're in a great
recession or a great depression when
they say we're not so why spend like
that
well you need to really make a
distinction between the you know the the
american rescue plan the the big bill
that was passed in march which was
spending like we were in a depression
because we kind of were um and this next
initiative because that's already in the
past now and the stuff looking forward
is not we're not we're not we're not
talking now about massive spending
relative to this relative to the size of
the economy as i said you know 3.5
trillion sounds like a lot until you
realize that it's taking place since
it's over a decade in an economy with is
going to produce 300 trillion dollars
worth of stuff it just is not depression
level spending it's it's a a fairly
modest thing it's it's a boost for
around one percent of gdp in public
investment uh so now
i think there's a lot of smooshing
together you know of the issue was there
too much stimulus in march which is
still i think it was okay but that was a
legitimate question and then question of
but is this further spending a big risk
and it's not it's just if you do the
math it just doesn't work that way
so paul the next big economic fight
seems to be over raising the debt
ceiling senate minority leader mitch
mcconnell straight up told democrats to
include it in the budget reconciliation
because the gop won't back it later it
seems bizarre to me and to much of the
rest of the world watching that the
richest economy in the history of the
world goes through this ridiculous debt
ceiling brinksmanship every few years no
other western economy does this
nobody does this this is it's insane
congress passes bills dictating spending
and taxes but then it has to pass a
separate bill that allows the government
to borrow the amount of money that is
implied by the tax and spending
legislation that's already passed so
it's crazy uh and you know what we're
doing what we're seeing here is some
brinksmanship the biden people think
that in the end mcconnell will not force
the u.s economy into default
um and uh that's
you know i
i've learned not to take anything for
granted but it would be a heck of a
thing to do and and they they do feel i
think there's a widespread sense that
obama got rolled that obama allowed
himself to be bullied into into giving
into stuff because his opponents seemed
ready to bring the whole house crashing
down on top of everybody and biden
doesn't want to do that
you mentioned that they don't want to
get rolled like obama we hear that a lot
from people in the administration even
people like ron claim the chief of staff
who served in that administration about
lessons learned from the obama era you
were you know you chronicled the obama
years the debate over health care uh the
republican approach to everything that
happened on his watch the stimulus do
you think this administration joe biden
his former vice president and many of
the ex obama people in this
administration have learned the lessons
of that era sufficiently is that what
the first eight months has taught us or
not
i think in large part i mean there are
some people who worry that they wasted
too much time you know what there was
the political maneuvering involved in
getting a you know a partial
infrastructure bill done in a bipartisan
way was that worth it or should they
just have gone to reconciliation right
away
but that's political strategizing but
the fact the matter is that biden is
actually moving big and fast
you know the um uh if i i had
i was tearing my hair out during 2009
over over obama's caution over the all
of these half measures and the one thing
that biden is not doing is is proposing
half measures this this is big stuff he
is trying to get um a lot of important
stuff done while he has
well he has that the political power to
do it
paul you've been chronicling the right
descent into i don't know what to call
it insanity extremism for more than a
decade now in a recent column for the
new york times on the gop's climate and
coveted denialism you conclude and i
quote the rights dissent continues with
no bottom in sight
what does that mean for america what
does that mean for american democracy
which depends on a two-party system
yeah i don't know i mean i mean i'm i'm
fairly optimistic about you know current
policy developments i think we have good
people in charge who have a pretty good
idea of what they're doing but how long
can we function when
slightly less than half the country um
basically is is an allegiance to
complete craziness when
when people you know
it used to seem like a big thing
that republicans could believe that
climate science was all this vast
conspiracy but now they literally have
you know the hospitals in florida
are full to capacity children are dying
and they're still refusing to believe in
in the science refusing to believe from
what's right in front of their eyes how
long can
this democracy survive if that many
people are willing to
to go that far down
so on that one last quick question for
you as i say you've been covering this
stuff for a long time uh you were ahead
of the curve on many of these issues
especially the gop are you optimistic or
pessimistic about the future of american
democracy given all these different
headwinds
oh boy uh
this really depends on uh we go uh on
the on that how am i feeling after the
first cup of coffee i mean it's it's
it's scary as heck i mean if you if you
are terrified you're not paying
attention but but i'm not giving up hope
well said paul krugman thank you so much
for your time and your insights tonight
i appreciate it
hi i'm mehdi hussain thanks for checking
out our channel on youtube you can see
more of the mehdi hassan show by
clicking on any of the videos on this
screen and make sure you subscribe below
to stay up to date on the day's biggest
stories thank you for watching